you or someone you care about may have
been diagnosed with a blood cancer this
video will help you understand how it
can be
managed blood cancer also known as
hematologic cancer begins in blood
forming tissu such as bone marrow bone
marrow is the spongy tissue inside your
bones that makes blood cells or blood
cancer may start within the cells of the
immune system examples of blood cancer
are leukemia
lymphoma and multiple
Myoma treatments such as chemotherapy
radiation therapy targeted therapy
immunotherapy and stem cell transplant
May control blood cancers depending on
the type of cancer and other
factors it is important to have a care
plan in place not only for receiving
therapy and personal care but also for
follow-up care this includes scheduling
and going to follow-up appointments
in addition to checking your General
Health and well-being your doctor will
want to check for any signs of the
cancer returning and check for health
problems that may have resulted from
treatment for example you may have tests
and imaging studies performed including
taking samples of your blood fluid
around your spinal cord or bone marrow
to check for cancer as relevant for your
situation continue taking all your
medications as prescribed do not stop
taking them without talking to your
doctor it is helpful to take notes for
points to discuss at your next doctor's
visit this could include any side
effects you may have
noticed if you've had treatments such as
chemotherapy radiation therapy or a bone
marrow transplant follow any
instructions you were
given there are lifestyle changes that
can improve your health and help you
feel better there are benefits to
stopping smoking this lowers the risk
for cancer return turning or spreading
it's generally accepted that eating a
healthy diet can help you feel better
and stronger both during and after
treatment physical activities like
walking riding a bicycle or swimming can
help you feel better and less tired talk
to your doctor before starting an
exercise
routine knowing you have cancer can be
overwhelming you may have worries about
your condition and how sick you could
get how it will affect you and your
family treatments and Hospital state
medical bills and your job there are
ways to find support for you remember
that your doctor and Healthcare team are
there to answer any questions you
have the following sources of support
can help you social workers Faith
leaders counselors and support
groups talk to your doctor if you have
any questions about your treatment plan
medications or lifestyle changes to help
you manage your blood cancer